[Music]
good morning Vietnam
I don't actually know if we have any
fans in Vietnam but it is morning there
I checked alright welcome to the Dark
Horse podcast livestream this is what
our 14th miss our 14th I am sitting with
dr. Heather hang as has become our habit
and we have lots of things that we were
we're excited to discuss with you today
do we have any housekeeping up front
other than asking people please like
subscribe and hit the notification bell
and be sure to set it to notify you
always of content on this channel as
people who do not have it set to always
sometimes miss out and they discover
that we are going live for example with
no morning you had also said something
about dressing super chef questions
which we'll do in the second livestream
right
quite correct yes we will be addressing
your super chat questions in the second
livestream but as an experiment and I
think it went well I announced on
Twitter that I would take two questions
from Twitter and so that the suspense
does not kill those people who submitted
questions over Twitter I will tell you
that re I will have us answer your
question about Madagascar's announced
cure and Brandon angler we will address
your question of how our concept of
collective consciousness maps onto
Jung's concept of collective the
collective unconscious so you can look
forward to those in the super traps
section which we will get to in well
we'll do this for about an hour and then
we'll have a 15 minute break and then we
will return to address those questions
so you can file Supercat questions here
and we will collect them and then we
will collect some more questions in the
second stream yeah we'll get through as
many as we can but we never get through
all of them yeah there's never enough
time alright
did you want to start off yeah I have a
little a little syllabic we like thing
to start us off with which you are then
I imagine go to riff on and that'll set
us off oh so I wanted to start by
thanking many of the people in the
audience who disagree with us
about some or many points but keep
coming back nevertheless to hear what a
conversation between two people who are
interested in discovering the truth
sounds like and hopefully also to learn
to figure out where you might be wrong
where we might be wrong where maybe both
of us are wrong not just both of us but
you know your understanding and our
understanding might both be wrong on
something we've heard directly for many
of you and we appreciate you in the last
couple weeks though we've noticed an
uptick in people offering critique that
isn't really critique it's fascinating
really what agendas and traits people
will attribute to others when what they
actually want to say is I disagree and I
can't defend the disagreement so there
are lots of names for the various
fallacies at home and being one of them
where you attack the person within the
ideas there may be there may well be
reason to disagree with us on any number
of fronts but saying for instance as
I've heard a number of times now you
have secured jobs so it's easy to defend
the lockdown is a non argument pointing
out possible conflicts of interest for
people making arguments is a legitimate
approach but this one isn't aside from
that the spells are not accurate aside
from that this particular accusation
this doesn't try to be true right we
have secured jobs during so lockdown as
melius to us just isn't true most
listeners will know in fact that we did
have secure jobs jobs that appeared
secure anyway they were supposed to be
secure for life but Bret and then I
stood up to the loons who had taken over
the college we were tenured and so very
long story short we're not college
professors anymore and we haven't been
for closing in on three years this fall
we don't have an employer so we don't
have salaries so we don't have employer
sponsored health care we do have reached
though now far more than we did when we
were professors and that has allowed us
to do these live streams and find
audience and that reach was also
necessary and giving the wonderful book
contract that we've got and so I'm not
saying this to complain but I am saying
that reach is not the same as security
or salary and with regard to the
particular topics that we are often
interested in raising reaching people
may in fact be in a trade-off
relationship with
so I still believe that the vast number
of people on both sides of the aisle
that is the political metaphor stemming
from the truth in the United States
Senate that people Democrats and
Republicans sit literally on opposite
sides of the aisle people on both sides
of the aisle are good-hearted good-faith
and legitimately interested in hearing
what people of different opinions have
to say I think the vast majority of
people it is true for but I see a world
that is polarizing fast and we've
alluded to this in maybe each of our
last live streams that we see we see
this star bellies niches and Sneetches
without landscape people wearing masks
and people without people wearing Mag of
hats and people without and it's become
this easy tell by which you can imagine
that you know everything else that's
true about a person and and not think
any further about what might be true of
them I want to say that more and more
people on the far left but what we're
seeing right now is more and more people
on the far right are taking personal
umbrage at those who see the world
differently from them and take it as
evidence that those people with whom
they disagree are themselves stupid or
incompetent or even evil and one of the
up shots of our rather dramatic
expulsion from Evergreen is that many
good people on the right are familiar
with us now and fun value when we say
this has I think led algorithms by
YouTube and the like to promote our
videos along with those of actual right
leading people in fact I spent a little
time logged in not as myself looking to
see what videos were suggested after
ours and and sure enough it looks like
we've been we've been logged in that way
in among some right leading videos which
is not in and of itself a bad thing but
it does mean that when the uninitiated
when those people who don't know us
click on our videos and find us
critiquing bad ideas across the board
bad ideas on the right and bad ideas on
the left we're more likely to hear
objections from people on the right
because they're more likely to have had
their expectations broken
by the algorithms and and by us but not
because we were ever dishonest about
where what we are we're on the Left
we've been saying that forever
even as the pseudo progressives at
Evergreen called us racists and fascists
and Nazis and all that jazz
people on the Left get upset we don't
critique Trump or the Republicans enough
and then when we do critique policies
coming out of the White House we are
told that we're only critiquing them
because we're knee-jerk lefties can't
win except we're you know we're trying
to thread this this needle walk this
line carefully and I want to say that
Trump derangement syndrome is is real
and some people can't see anything
coming from the current administration
as positive or potentially positive but
TDS Trump derangement syndrome has a
mirror image syndrome which I'll call
proud Trump derangement syndrome and the
probe derangement syndrome guys can't
about any critique of the man's actions
or policies and that's just as knee-jerk
and just as deranged frankly so that's
not how democracy works it's not how we
any of us not just spread into me but
any of us refine our understanding of
the world to make it a better and better
match for reality we need people to
share information to analyze it and we
need critique of both the information
and the analysis we need to imagine that
with rare exceptions nobody is wholly
wrong and nobody is wholly right I think
that some of where this confusion is
coming from can be can be found in how
science is actually taught it's we have
we have here and elsewhere critiqued
modern education and specifically modern
science education quite a lot and we
will continue to do so but how science
is taught and therefore understood by
much of the population is you're given
litanies of facts to memorize at school
and you aren't offered a dive into the
scientific method which is in fact the
core of science so if what you think
science is is a rote list of facts that
are true have always been understood to
be true and we'll always understood to
be true you will think that uncertainty
is failure and it's unsigned
what in fact it's the exact opposite
uncertainty is not failure total
certainty in fact especially in the face
of new and rapidly changing landscapes
like the one we find ourselves in with
this pandemic is anti-scientific it will
likely total certainty you will likely
sell soda and chips and anxiety and
despair but it was not gonna help anyone
gain understanding it it's like everyone
wants superheroes and supervillains but
has never actually fact checked to see
if they've ever met any of those not
only are superheroes and supervillains
vanishingly rare if not completely
non-existent news accounts are often
gonna be a mixed bag as well as our
scientific results this is to be
expected this is what complexity looks
like demanding certainty and categorical
results is a juvenile position what
you'll get if you demand certainty and
categorical categorical results is
garbage
sold to you and less understanding of
what the world is how it works and how
you might change it for the better
so in conclusion before I hand off to
you we're going to be wrong sometimes
everyone's going to be wrong sometimes
and also sometimes the reality that we
discover or that we reveal that other
people have discovered through
scientific analysis or just through the
passage of time as for instance this
virus reveals itself to be something
that we don't currently understand it to
be it's gonna be ugly sometimes and not
to our liking that everyone is sometimes
wrong first and that reality is
sometimes ugly our universal truths you
can't change reality though by denying
it or by calling the people talking
about it bad names or ascribing motives
to them that don't exist or irrelevant
to the conversation you could however
understand that reality as best as you
can and use that newfound knowledge and
useful and honorable ways well that's
excellent there's a lot there that gives
voice to some things I've been thinking
as well I didn't get all the way to
coming up with the name for whatever the
mirror image of of Trump derangement
syndrome is but I have been thinking I
have never seen anything like this
before
the idea of a Pres
who is beyond critique is an absurdity
and we can argue whether you know Trump
is much more deserving of critique than
others who might inhabit the office but
nonetheless the very idea that you can't
critique him without evidencing some
sort of a confusion or a hidden agenda
or something like that is very upsetting
and I think there's a way in which it
actually emerges from the man himself
and I'm reminded when we were college
professors and it was not infrequent
that we would end up advising students
we knew our students quite well because
of the way Evergreen worked so our
students were full-time students in our
single program that we taught and you
know we knew them all by name knew many
of their lives pretty well and they
would ask us for advice and one of the
pieces of advice that I found I found
myself giving very frequently was don't
even consider marrying anybody who
doesn't have a sense of humor about
myself they're just not marriage
material which i think is an upsetting
problem because there are a lot of
people in that category and it's sad to
think that they may not be appropriate
for a relationship but wow I wouldn't
elect anybody president who didn't have
a sense of humor about themselves either
and while this president does an awful
lot of joking it is almost always at
other peoples expense and he is
incredibly thin-skinned when he any
critique comes his way which in light of
the fact that he does not appear to be
expert in the kinds of things that he's
being called upon to navigate is is very
troubling indeed so if I can just add
one final thing you can tell very
frequently what kind of person someone
is based on how they deal with the
discovery that they have been in correct
and one thing you can do is you can
rationalize and sweep it under the rug
and pretend it didn't happen
now you're wrong twice not only were you
wrong the first time
but you were claimed to have always been
in the position that you now hold is
also wrong so that is not an indication
character and we will be wrong we have
been wrong here and we have been careful
I think each time we have been wrong in
a significant way to come back and say
here's here's where it was and here's
how the error happened and boy let me
tell you it's not fun I don't like I
would very much like to be right
I don't like discovering that I'm wrong
and doing it in front of a large
audience is very difficult but the point
is Wow is it a better deal than sticking
with some wrong position so it's not to
admit that you made an error which is of
course human and it's always hard to
navigate you know when do you say you
know I've I'm putting my internal
estimation at 95% on this thing and I'm
gonna go ahead and say it and and with
you know without the sort of the error
bars built in and then okay maybe it's
one it's that one in 20 times that I was
wrong do you have to come back and fix
it or you speak in terms of
uncertainties and probabilities and you
know more often than not not numbers
explicitly but implicit numerical
thinking quantitative thinking and that
drives a lot of people crazy
not just because again our educational
system is so bad that most people who
should completely be able to understand
some quantitative thinking actually
can't through no fault of their own
often but it it also doesn't fit with a
landscape of buy-it-now get your answer
beyond your way have the thing in your
back pocket that you have to say when
someone asks you a question and don't
think about it ever again there is no
set and forget over in scientific
discovery space you can't do it that way
no you can't and in some sense I think
if we go upstream from the problem that
you started out pointing us towards it
is a consequence it's a downstream
consequence of the politicization of
everything and I think for those of us
who understand why science works and how
delicate the process is it's very
frightening to see it become politicized
because it still looks like science but
what it does is it eliminates our
ability to navigate
well in all of our interest it blinds us
right and you can get it what you know
if you're on the road going straight you
can afford to close your eyes for a few
seconds but the point is going straight
is it's a short road at that level and
we have to do better so we are now
seeing this come I don't know full
circle is the wrong term but we are
seeing it amplified by this crisis into
something very very dangerous where the
problem is where you fall out
politically is very likely to inform
your sense of whether or not it is safe
for America to open back up why does
that make any sense at all this is an
empirical question now we can you know
maybe differ over how many deaths we
would tolerate in order to get things
running again but I still haven't heard
that discussion actually yeah we have
raised that as a potential discussion
that is worth having I'll be at
dangerous and fraud but I haven't run
into that anywhere and you know I hope
and presume it's happening some places
but it really seems to be people yelling
at each other about you're wrong about
what you believe as opposed to here are
my values and we differ on values and
we're going to have to make some
difficult decisions it is suspicious
that the two things are fused together
if you believe that that we should open
back up then you believe that the number
of people who would be killed by our
doing so would be low right and in fact
these are two separate questions people
will die either way we can have a
discussion about what number of deaths
would be tolerable and then we can have
a discussion about what the evidence
suggests would happen and those are two
distinct things but by fusing them
together we can recognize that this is a
purely political discussion but the
scientific community is also
artificially United behind these
positions that are in many cases just
absolutely upsetting and if I can make
this personal for a second there's
something incredibly troubling some
weeks ago
maybe it's months ago at this point I
said what I thought was a perfectly
nuanced thing over Twitter about
vaccines which as I said we favor them
we have vaccinated our children but I
still don't believe that we fully
understand the dangers or that they're
completely safe and I doubt but you know
hopefully you heard me say I'm leaving
them enough that we vaccinated our
children so I'm a believer in vaccine is
potentially one of the most important
health discoveries in all of Medicine
absolutely and in fact our family is
probably much more vaccinated than
almost any other American family simply
because of the amount of tropical travel
we've done and the additional number of
vaccines that one gets in order to go to
places with a large slew of diseases
that you don't run into if you're in the
US so just yeah there is evidence right
there in the first part of what you said
isn't a feint it's not a lie no it is it
is absolutely fundamental to the
statement but the second part of the
statement is also true second part is
true and the pushback I got over Twitter
even from some sophisticated people was
effectively we cannot have a nuanced
discussion here you you have to toe the
party line
now why is anybody telling me that I
have to toe the scientific party line
first of all I've earned a credential
that allows me to say what I think and
maybe it comes with you know you can
decide my degree is meaningless maybe it
is but but the point is it's at least
somebody who knows a bit of biology is
saying actually on balance I'm doing
this thing but I'm not all that
comfortable with the safety my work on
the question of drug safety and mice
suggests that maybe I have even more
insight but how is it that you can
search for those few who don't know what
you're talking about there's a lot more
to be said here but you can look at your
brother's Eric Weinstein's portal
episode remember the number it's 1919
okay with you from I guess it was
released while we were in the Amazon so
January of this year in which you tell
the story yeah but in any case it's not
you know at the point that people were
accusing us of racism and we were forced
to resign from our
our professional lives these people
didn't rally to our defense academia was
more or less silent with a few few
notable exceptions you know Robbie
George and Jonathan - hi Gary coin right
but by and large academia was quiet and
certainly there was not enough of a
groundswell to protect us Christakis so
of course but in any case at the point
that we want to talk nuance about the
safety of drugs or vaccines or any of
those things yeah we have to do it
responsibly but but to get this pushback
that says actually no you have to tear
the party line where does that habla
toward is that sense of obligation even
come from
well and it's it reminds me actually of
conversations that we had in graduate
school in the 90s in which we were told
by a professor whom we respected greatly
in many regards and who at the time it
was early in grad school so we were
thinking we were looking for who to work
with and he told us that there just some
questions then that one should not ask
because the answers might be ugly oh and
the questions were indeed the questions
that are now they've become a focus for
us and they are the things that make
people nervous about evolutionary
psychology and they're around whether or
not there are differences between the
sexes and what they might be and whether
or not there are differences between the
races and what they might be those sorts
of things yep all right so maybe we
should move from this discussion into
another land of nuance where we find a
bizarrely monolithic and on nuanced
presentation from the expert class Zak
do you want to put up the PDF file yeah
we can't see it yet so what this is is a
quick and dirty flowchart that I put
together that basically tracks my own
internal understanding of the likelihood
of the kovat 19 pandemic having arisen
through differ
pathways so on the far left here you can
see wild coronavirus transmitted
directly from a bat to a human in the
wild and I've got that at something like
a 2% likelihood and then there if you
look at the second box from the left you
see it having gone from a wild bat to a
human through the seafood market so not
somebody traveling through a cave and if
where did that if that were to have
happened directly I would say there's
probably a 2% chance of something like
that having happened if it went through
an intermediate like a Pangolin then I
would give that maybe 3% and my point
here is not to defend each of these
percentages you'll see that the date
here is May 9th when I initially
intended to show this diagram I didn't
faint it because I have seen nothing
since May 9th that has appreciably
altered my understanding of these
probabilities you'll see some we talked
in some depth in the episode it's called
an intelligent design I think about why
you put why we both put the chances that
this was actually some sort of a hybrid
or a genetically engineered virus at
such a high number yes so you defend
these numbers not in terms of the actual
numbers but you defend the relative
values in an earlier life yes and in
fact I will say that the estimate my
estimate of how likely this is to be an
engineered virus has actually gone up
since that live stream based on further
analyses that I've seen so anyway my
point here I've got a couple of them one
is internally whatever dialogue you're
having with yourself you'd be wise to
put together something like this a so
you can track the change in your opinion
over time and you don't fool yourself
into thinking that you've believed X Y
or Z all along
B it allows you to step away from the
artificial certainty that colors many of
the discussions that we find ourselves
having right so in my mind I
I know from the fact that I actually
went through the exercise of putting
this on paper that I think that there's
close to a 90% chance that this was an
accidental escape from a laboratory
right now that percentage could go down
and as I've said elsewhere I hope that
it does I am rooting for the explanation
for this pandemic to be some sort of a
natural encounter with a naturally
occurring virus
I don't want science to be responsible
for this because I am depending on
science to help get us out of the
terrible situation that we find in our
find ourselves in in civilization and if
we scientists are in some sense
responsible for what has happened here
that's a huge setback nonetheless I'm
not going to let that affect what I
think the likelihood is my second point
here would be why is it that as trained
biologists yes we are not virologists we
are not epidemiologist but as trained
biologists looking at the vast quantity
of information and analysis available to
us you and I come out so far from the
established community of I religious who
for all I can tell those who are
involved in being paid as the viral
adjusts at top-tier places are united in
their claim that this couldn't have come
from the lab in either of the labs at
Wuhan and even if it's our circled even
if they are correct that it didn't I
can't see where they would come out with
it couldn't have right how do you get to
a zero or a hundred percent probability
right now were you in the the lab in the
primary lab in Wuhan they Shanxi is a
Shang Lee lab in Wuhan you might know a
great deal more than the rest of the
community in other words you might know
that the sequence doesn't match anything
to pass through your lab
and therefore it had to have come a
different route but how the rest of the
community arrives there is very unclear
in light of the fact that responsibility
if this did come through that lab will
rest with them and therefore there's a
tremendous burden for them to lie to
themselves if possible and if not to
potentially tell the world a much
clearer story then makes sense so what I
would suggest in fact I will call upon
the virality community to do some
soul-searching we ought to be a very
easy pair to convince if this is
actually a compelling story if we've
misunderstood something yeah we ought to
be very easy to convince if we are not
convincing because the story isn't
nearly as clear as you're painting it it
is time for people to acknowledge the
ambiguity and it is necessary that you
do so because I would like to point out
what happens if you don't if you don't
acknowledge the ambiguity in this story
and the data continues to suggest a
strong possibility of this having
emerged accidentally or otherwise from
laboratories then the entire virology
community will have rest its rested its
reputation on a false claim and at this
moment we cannot afford to have the
entire virality community compromised by
a lie so what I want to see is some
acknowledgement that this is an
ambiguous story and for those of you who
are not in the virality community I want
you to think about the following thing I
want you to recognize that every time
you are told that this is not an
engineered virus and that it didn't come
through a lab you are being told
implicitly that the fact that this virus
shows up first in a place that has two
virality labs studying coronaviruses in
bats is a coincidence even though the
Batson question do not occur in that
location so if nothing else that is an
amazing level of coincidence
and those who are telling us that this
story is secure should acknowledge it
upfront they should say we know we
finally we know this this is hard to
believe but this didn't come from a lab
even though it shows up in a place where
there were two labs it might have come
from those labs are not widespread and
the bats otherwise do not occur in this
locale all right you can take that
diagram seems to be down
okay can we segue from there I promised
on Twitter maybe unwisely to suggest an
alteration in the names that we apply I
actually think that talking briefly
about the critiques the plan Democratic
cellent segue first okay there first so
we talked last time just a little bit
about the the plan Demick the
documentary that's maybe two hours and
which has a lot of stuff in it is just
clearly ridiculous
and then the 28th minute my shorter
version that has mostly an interview
with Judy do you know how to pronounce
that make of it's my case
I think it's make of it okay megabits
who was a virologist who's making a lot
of remarkable claims and we basically
said last time we're probably not good
as we were asked by a lot of people to
basically take it apart piece by piece
and give our critique and we said
there's a lot wrong as a few things that
seem right and that leaves so much that
we can't assess individually that we're
really not sure that it's worth our time
so what I want to do rather than
critique yet two point by point is point
to Zack if you would put up what's on my
computer screen now this is a
journalistic piece that was published in
science some of the two major scientific
journals worldwide called fact-checking
Judy McComb it's the controversial
virologist attacked Anthony foul she in
a viral conspiracy video the viral
conspiracy video being I think the
twenty eight minute long one that is
that we have seen so I want to point out
this is and this is this is science
science magazine science the Journal of
record where if you can get your
empirical results or your theoretical
results
in this journal that where nature is
where you want to be and they say these
this these two authors these two science
journalists critique the her points
excellently mostly so among other things
I'll just read a couple of them she says
in the video I was held in jail with no
charges and they revealed that she's
dishonestly portraying her own history
that the charges were clear and she was
in jail for a couple of days and that's
not to downplay the idea of being in
jail for a couple of days but the
charges were always clear so dishonestly
portraying your own history is a red
flag for sure she says there was no
vaccine currently on the schedule for
any RNA virus that works yeah we were
asked about this in the Q&A last time
and we weren't sure someone said oh yeah
for sure for other species and these
guys say yeah actually there are
vaccines for the following RNA viruses
influenza measles mumps rubella rabies
yellow fever and Ebola so that's kind of
a long list actually she says wearing
the masks that really activates your own
virus you're getting sick from your own
reactivated coronavirus expressions and
if it happens to be SARS Cove 2 then
you've got a big problem so when I saw
this I thought what should she mean by
coronavirus expressions what is that
even what does that even refer to that's
not a term of art in science as far as I
know and the authors of this piece say
the same thing there's also you I've
seen nothing anywhere suggesting that
wearing a mask can activate viruses and
make people sick the ridiculous
arguments early on were that it won't do
any good and it turns out that those are
mostly political arguments to keep
people from stockpiling PPE is when they
should be reserved for health care
workers that's at least the most
generous interpretation of what was
going on but this is the first and only
time I've ever seen anyone say actually
masks masks wearing itself will make you
sick and this also sounds like
gobbledygook and this is the point that
you referenced last time brett she says
why would you close the beach you've got
sequences in the soil in the sand you've
got healing microbes in the ocean in the
salt water that's insanity
so as regular viewers of this these live
streams will be aware we also think the
closing the beach is a mistake
and has been from the beginning but what
mecha Fitz means by sand or soil
sequences and how they might be relevant
to people being healed by being out
there is is like I say gobbledygook so
you can I think you can take that down
now Zack that all seems like these
science journalists is a really
compelling job basically point-by-point
taking taking what she said in order and
and disabusing us the readers the
viewers of the sense that she has any
credibility at all but there there are a
few places in the same article where
they make exactly the sort of circling
the wagons style arguments that you were
just talking about quote there is no
evidence this bat virus is manipulated
believe it or not come down on that side
of the equation or not there are plenty
of people talking about it there is a
lot of evidence that's been produced
across a lot of domains so the idea that
science the premier American Journal of
science scientific communication of
scientific findings can say with no
apparent irony there is no evidence this
bat virus was manipulated in an
otherwise thorough and it seems well
researched takedown of Mike Ovitz makes
a person wonder and there's one more of
these at least she says in the video
Mick Abbott says heads of our tired
Department of Health and Human Services
colluded and destroyed my reputation and
the Department of Justice and the FBI
sat on it and kept that case under seal
and the science article responds Mike
Ovitz has presented no direct evidence
that HHS heads colluded against her now
I'm not saying they did I have no idea
but the idea that you need to provide
direct evidence of collusion against you
in origin demonstrate this collusion
against you reminds me of that moment in
the year before we left Evergreen when
you started talking about the culture of
fear that was taking over and you
literally had our colleagues coming to
you saying prove that there's a culture
of fear
tell us who's scared yeah you can't the
idea that her lacking direct evidence of
the collusion is evidence of lack of
collusion is laughable so what do you do
with that
almost everything in the video that the
plenty McVie do is ridiculous
but not all of it well and you know I
mean I'm glad you came around in the end
to this point about what do you do with
a article that appears to make many
valid points and has fused them two
points that to my mind are effectively
indefensible right to say there's no
evidence of this being an engineered
virus well yet you can set an
evidentiary standard where there is no
evidence but then no evidence is
conceivable yeah because if you wanted
to talk about what the preponderance of
evidence said in this case it does point
in that direction and in fact raises all
kinds of questions about whether this
virus even could have come from nature
in the form that we saw it so you have
science here that is doing this the
giant the journal Science doing this job
where it has taken true points and
points that appear to be false and has
linked them together in such a way that
first of all laypeople will you know at
best come away with the sense of I don't
know what that is but make it go away
which means that they will miss the good
points but we also have the journal
Nature doing this so the wagons have
been circled amongst all of the
establishment biologists and the two
major journals that are you know as you
said the journals of record are both
selling a false story that you know it's
not that they need to come out with some
sort of conclusion in the other
direction there's still ambiguity here
but what is clear is that there's a
great deal of uncertainty with respect
to origin and there is an awful lot of
evidence and you know as I said last
time the evidence that there is
something very odd about this virus and
that it emerged from a lab in one way or
another is growing stronger not weaker
so the trend over time is pointing in
the other direction all right which does
lead me to the point about the name of
this virus and disease I am increasingly
troubled that a phenomenon which
affecting almost all of seven plus
billion people on this planet either
directly or indirectly is traveling
under names that function as jargon so I
I will argue that there are things
called terms of art these are technical
terms that you actually need in order to
have a proper discussion and then
there's jargon which are terms that are
artificially complicated in order to
keep people who are not in the club from
discussing them properly and
unfortunately the names that we're using
both kovat 19 and SARS Cove - both of
these things are like something that you
would label a specimen or a vial with
these are not proper terms for us to be
discussing these phenomena what's more
they're not even accurate in the case of
SARS Cove - well it turns out over time
the medical complications are rising
from this virus are so perplexing and
vast - to call this a respiratory
syndrome at all is misleading I mean
it's causing heart attacks and it's
causing strokes and it's causing you
know the loss of the sense of smell and
all sorts of other things so let me just
say that unlike the scientific names
over in normal organism space that's not
viral space which do not pretend to
indicate mechanism or something that is
something that accompanies the organism
itself the actual name here the
scientific name is this hybrid of a
description of the phylogeny of the
history which is the Cove part the
coronavirus part and the SARS which is
kind of an indicator of the history but
it's also an indicator of the effect
that it has severe acute respiratory
syndrome being what's our stands for so
it's this it's this confusing hybrid of
kind of what over in non-human space we
would call the ecology in the deep
history combined in a name which is
supposed to really only reflect the deep
history the ecology is to be discovered
by other people at other times right and
the 19 in kovat 19
technically defensible in the sense that
it started in nineteen as far as we know
is out of phase with the fact that
mostly it's unfolding in twenty and so
in any case these names stuck and I'm
not arguing that professionals need to
stop using them if it facilitates your
work in a hospital or laboratory you
know go right ahead but for the rest of
us the terms that we use to discuss
whether or not we can afford to you know
to relax the lockdown for example the
term should be accessible to everybody
they should be you know English words
for example so I'm going to suggest that
a we've been told that we mustn't
reference China or Wuhan because that's
racist somehow and I think this is
garbage because what we know is that the
most recent common ancestor of the virus
that is currently spreading across the
globe and causing so much illness
started in Wuhan now if you look at my
diagram haze that can you put my diagram
back up if you look at my diagram you'll
see I've left I think it's a 1% chance
over on the far right for this having
been an intentional release I think the
chances of this are very low but if it
was intentionally released then it would
make sense that it was intentionally
released in one in order to mislead us
about its source you would release it
somewhere where there was a lab that
people would come to blame but in any
case even under that scenario the fact
is it began to spread in Wuhan so I'm
gonna argue that the proper terms for
this should be the Wuhan enigma virus
since there's much that is unknown about
it and given the amount that is
medically unclear about it
Wuhan enigma syndrome and I think those
capture where we are they properly allow
us to describe a syndrome that seems to
be just simply adding new symptoms by
the day and it does not artificially
confine us to regarding this as a
respiratory illness or
illness or whatever else we might be
tempted to do and I think it leaves open
the full range of possibilities for
where this thing was generated if that's
what happened and certainly where it
emerged and began to spread so I'm gonna
push back on this all right it's true
that we do call many diseases by the
names that they were most of the places
that they were most associated with
Spanish flu being the easy example it's
been discussed a lot because it's 101
years ago or I think is when that that
pandemic happened but the place is again
an aspect of the ecology and in general
the names the and I think maybe what's
not clear but I'm not sure you made
clear but what is clear between us that
we know about scientific names the
naming naming of organisms in general is
that there is always some some Latin
binomial when it's an organism that's on
the Tree of Life it's not a virus some
to two-word name like Homo sapiens or
felis Silvestri's or Canis familiaris
humans domestic cats domestic dogs that
with that genus and specific epithet you
can actually implied in that is the
entire history of the lineage all the
way back in time to the origin of life
on Earth you can't do the same thing
with viruses right because viruses are
polyphyletic I mean the meaning that
they have multiple origins and we don't
know whatever many of those are canoes
or origins were and they presumably
sometimes emerged out of the tree of
life that was already extent so we can't
have nearly such a clear phylogenetic
name but the cove the cove part of Cyrus
Cove too is descriptive it stands for
coronavirus and so I didn't I'm not
prepared here as you know I was thinking
I wanted to do a whole names thing and
you maybe I'll do it as a separate video
but you know there is a nested set of
viruses within viral sub families and
families and all that you can take out
and take out into ever more inclusive
sets
The Cove part the coronavirus part is a
real evolutionary entity that abandoning
that in this seems to me like that's a
huge huge loss but what we don't have is
a distinction between actually everyone
is stuck using the scientific name
because whereas when it's a Warbler I
don't know if it's the birders or who
they get to decide the common name and
boy birders come up with some funky
fancy common names for birds but right
now the scientists the virologists are
coming up with with the scientific names
and the politicians are jostling for the
common name and you're proposing a new
common name but it sounds to me like
it's just as murky and messy and as all
the rest what it doesn't have is an
acronym that many people wouldn't know
what it meant but to the extent that
you're defending kovat right well I was
I was defending stars koch2 covin 19
being the disease is this I think it's
actually more pronounceable so but I was
I was not defending the name of the
disease so much in part because I know
almost nothing about how diseases tend
to be named that the name of an organism
is something in which you and I both
have substantial background we
understand not only what happens but why
it tends to happen and I think I have a
fairly fairly good grasp of sort of
where the bodies are buried and what
makes sense
whereas how disease has come to be named
you know I know far less and it seems to
me that it is inherently political think
this one was named by the who which is
another reason to dislike it that the
amount of misinformation and
false starts out of the who does not
suggest that they're naming convention
is one that we ought to inscribe into
history but so SARS Cove - you think
SARS is still an appropriate way to
refer to this well I think again I'm not
I'm not prepared for this the way I have
been in previous life students and we
didn't get to it but if memory serves
SARS which appears to be a cycle
description severe acute respiratory
syndrome which describes what people who
get this get infected with this virus
experience has become an indicator of
the place on the phylogeny and I'm not
saying that's wise but it's a little bit
like chiroptera right so chiroptera
means hand weighing it's the it's the
LAT dame for the group of animals that
everyone else knows as bats but i use it
because yeah you've been a bat biologist
at some point in the past right so hand
wing describes a piece of you know the
the anatomy that allows for the ecology
that is really totally descriptive of
bats that's okay
even though bats could or you know
tetrapods
the four-legged animals that emerge onto
land there's still tetrapods even when
there's snakes it's not really accurate
anymore snakes don't have four legs but
they're still part of that history so if
if I'm right I'm not sure I'm right that
SARS in this case is describing a
particular piece of the history of the
finally genetics then it does belong
there even though it is a Miss a bad
description of what it causes in people
all right I don't know how many other
people are gonna care about this but
I've got you right where I want because
now you're telling me that SARS even
though the last s in SARS stands for
syndrome yeah that that is an
appropriate phylogenetic delineator and
it came at us the whole point of a
syndrome is that a syndrome allows us to
describe the symptoms of a disease
without knowing its cause
so back before HIV was understood we
knew about AIDS AIDS was a syndrome
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome and
the point is here is a set of symptoms
and we know you're sick with something
but we don't know what it is later on
the discovery of HIV tells us okay it's
this particular particle acting in this
particular way and that particular
particle is related to other particles
that we can go find in nature so I I
think SARS is just a a bad descriptor
that came from the early understanding
of the symptomatology here and what
we're learning is that any sort of bias
is is a hazard here because for one
thing we're learning so much about
how you can't afford to treat this
normally because it may be that for
example a ventilator is dangerous to you
if you have a sufficiently strong
cytokine storm so anyway I don't know
how far to push it but I would say
there's a lot that is mysterious here
the nature of the virus is mysterious
the nature of the syndrome that follows
is mysterious we're learning a
tremendous amount and naming it in
anything other than anglish seems to me
unfair to the large number of people who
are simply having to tolerate our
scientific discussions of their fate and
you know if I were one of them I would
want in on those discussions and I would
want it described in English and you and
I would agree the worst possible thing
to happen is to allow the people who are
politicizing the issue to do the naming
so I'm proposing these two if you think
there are better ones I'm I'm all ears
okay where are we timewise 50 minutes
there's one set of things I want to do I
know you've got a lot more that you
could you could go after it
no go ahead okay well this this is in
the sort of Corrections addendums file
it's a this is a break from what we've
been talking about there's no natural
segue here I have a correction if you
don't get to it but we'll see if it's on
your list okay well this is this I've
just have the one really I integrated
one already into we didn't say that
there weren't any vaccines for RNA
viruses but we weren't sure and I listed
a bunch that were revealed in the
science article and there's a question
last time in the Q&A for live stream 13
about a report out in the military times
that the DoD it apparently restricted
coronavirus survivors from enlisting and
we didn't know about it at the time and
we even thought Oh military times don't
know if that's a legit site turns out it
is a legit site and the story is
interesting and it continues to evolve
so you might show this screen just
briefly Zack this is not the story that
was alluded to in that question but a
follow up story actually so originally
the Pentagon had said actually we're not
going to let any
any survivors of wait for it ghovat
nineteen to enlist in the US Armed
Services at all . and there was pushback
considerable pushback and the Pentagon
then said as reported in this slightly
later military Times article that its
narrowing it's banned only prohibiting
those who've been hospitalized for the
disease and there's a more even a more
recent story now excuse me that suggests
that there's at least one Republican
lawmaker who is pushing back against
that ban entirely so that's that's all
very interesting in response to the
question in real time in the last
livestream I had this 390 of response
actually I said why would they restrict
survivors from listening and I really
given how much we've heard over the
years about how how much difficulty the
US military has had time has had getting
conscripts like why why are they making
it harder now but our friend Holly who's
at Holly math nerd on Twitter pointed
out that this would seem to indicate
that there are long-term consequences to
the disease that we may not fully
understand yet but maybe the military is
either banking on the fact that they are
real or they know more than the rest of
us do about those long-term health care
concerns and that is actually now that
she says it now when she said it to me I
thought oh of course of course that
would be the reason to restrict people
who had been in this now they've have
changed it to very sick from this
disease from and listing in the future
maybe they don't want to pay for the
health care costs of their ongoing care
if it causes long-term damage like we
have said repeatedly on this it likely
does I mean it seems like you want to
add something here well I mean a I would
point out that this isn't permanent they
can certainly discover that they've been
too cautious and they can relax this
rule later I don't think it's a bad rule
in light of what we don't know here I
mean for one thing we don't know whether
or not you know there's no evidence for
but it could come back for people who
have had it it could recur and if that
happens
inside of a military unit under
you-know-who our housing together
somewhere that could be a major
vulnerability absolutely you know worse
if this was a bio weapon as you may have
seen on my chart I think the chances of
that are very low it's possible that it
escaped from bioweapon research but but
in any case the the risk in a military
context is significant enough the rule
isn't permanent so I don't see any
particular reason to complain about it I
did want to say I think it was my error
I said I wasn't sure about the military
times and then I did check into it and I
found the same thing you did it's
perfectly legitimate journalistic site
and so anyway my apologies let me just
say before you get to your correction
that was it oh right there okay that
this the same Holly friend of ours I
want to give a shout-out to her other
Twitter account which is great women of
mathematics at GW Oh maths and it's it's
really quite a wonderful site in which
she features women from mathematical
history and their contributions and
right now she's doing a she's got a
thread and a competition actually on the
200th anniversary of the birth I guess
of Florence Nightingale
who was a founder which I didn't know of
descriptive statistics yeah I had no
idea and as the thread says I'll just
quote from one of the tweets here
she made Statistics accessible to wide
audiences by furthering mathematically
sound methods of data visualization and
presentation and made them beautiful too
so who know amazing if you if you're
interested at all in math and and the
history of it and how it has changed
through time this is a really fabulous
site g-great women of math man yes he's
a great fellow on Twitter totally worth
it and you will join I don't know JK
Rowling that's right yeah tweeted about
her thread so anyway
a very very good choice on Twitter all
right so I think that covers everything
that I was looking to do here we should
take a 15-minute break and then we can
return to do come back and maybe we'll
start with those two Twitter questions
Brett that you pulled and then address
as many of the superjet questions from
this first live stream as we can in a
limited amount of time and then start
addressing those that come in during the
second live stream all right excellent
we will see you shortly
you